le théâtre d'art dramatique de mario
paul est devenu le théâtre d'un horrible
drame sous l'impact d'une bombe sur
cette vidéo partagée par le média en
ligne bélarusse n'existe à des résidents
de marioupol s'y abriter avant la tacc
que l'armée russe a nié l'attribuant à
des groupes nationalistes
selon les autorités locales des milliers
de civils ont péri dans cette ville
assiégée réduite à néant depuis le début
de l'invasion reflète
ceux qui ont pu fuir se réfugie à
sapporo jean dans cette arène de cirque
ils ont trouvé le répit de l'aide de la
nourriture des vêtements chauds
avant que sa maison à marioupol ne
s'effondre
dimitri avait passé une dizaine de jours
au théâtre de mario paul dit il il a
quitté sa ville hier maintien bourret
ilaria raconte les bombardements
incessants à mario paul elle dit avoir
passé dix jours à 6 avec son enfant dans
les bras dans le sous-sol de son
logement
autre ville autre drame une dizaine de
corps gisant sur le sol selon le média
ukrainiens ce spleen news ils ont été
touchés par des éclats d'obus alors
qu'il faisait la file pour avoir du pain
pour 10,4 source une information que
l'armée russe n'y ait que l'ambassade
américaine à kiev confirme sur twitter
un dessin d'enfant sur un mur d'école
attractives comme un pied de nez à la
guerre deux écoles ont été touchés par
les bombes ce résident de la ville
ramasse un éclat d'obus n'arrêtent pas
les semelles sur ce sont des cadeaux des
russes pour libérer le peuple russophone
ironise-t-il
le marché local également à feu et à
sang
il y avait plusieurs roquettes ou les
missiles grad boum boum boum puis le feu
s'est déclarée raconte cet homme un feu
qui a fait des victimes et qui a blessé
des pompiers
c'est toute l'ukraine qui s'est
réveillée sous les bombes
la capitale qui observent un couvre feu
jusqu'à jeudi n'a pas été épargné les
secouristes transportent les blessés et
réconfortés survivants
comme le fait le président zelensky en
conversation avec le maire de l'édito
paul ivan federov enlevé par les russes
libérés au bout du fil le maire remercie
le président zelensky de ne pas l'avoir
abandonnée n'abandonnons pas notre
peuple du répond-t-il
si sur le terrain les combats font rage
la cause de l'ukraine a été entendue à
la cour internationale de justice le
plus haut tribunal onusien qui a ordonné
à moscou de suspendre immédiatement ses
opérations militaires en ukraine ici s
mitraillette radio canada montréal